Speaker 1: An outrageous and shocking video
of now Congresswoman Marjorie Taylor Green
showing up at the House of Representatives
in February of twenty nineteen, going to Alexandria,
cacio Cortez's office and shouting outrageous
things through the mail slot in the door has
been found and published.
The video has since been deleted, and it really
starts to tell a bigger story about the obsessive
almost stalker like harassment of AOC by Marjorie
Taylor Green.
And the reason that this is again in the news
is that Marjorie Taylor Green confronted Alexandria
Castillo Cortez again outside the House chamber
last week.
And it has people talking about is this criminal?
Is this rising to the point of being stalking
in some sense and all sorts of other questions
we now have to add to this a new video which
shows a longer pattern of this ridiculous
behavior.
Check out the first part of the video.
Speaker 2: You want to talk to crazy AKCA.
You come to this little thing and you open
it up and you whisper into this is this is
this is a confession from
Speaker 3: Alexandria, AKCA Cortez.
I'm an American citizen.
I pay your salary through the taxes that you
collect for me through the IRS because I'm
a taxpaying citizen of the United States.
I'm a woman, I'm a female business owner.
Speaker 1: So that you really understand the
optics if you're just listening on the radio
or to the audio podcast.
In the video, Marjorie Taylor Green is bent
over at the waist, speaking through the mail
slot.
Unlocks door.
I like I'm a woman and I'm a female.
This woman is really disgusting.
I mean, just a vile, vile person.
Let's keep watching.
Speaker 3: And I'm proud to be an American
woman.
And I do not support your socialist policies
and I do not support your murderous abortion
policies.
As a mother of three children, I'm appalled
at New York's law for abortion.
And it needs to end and it needs to stop.
Now, you're bringing God's judgment on our
country and I'm against it as well as my friends.
Speaker 1: Now, I have to break in for a moment.
Not that any of this makes sense, but how
is New York State abortion policy related
to AOC?
AOC lived in New York and worked in jobs that
had nothing to do with policy.
And then she was elected a member of Congress
representing New York and Washington, DC.
Federally, the federal government doesn't
decide state law on abortion in New York.
You would think Marjorie Taylor Green might
know that since she's about states rights.
Let's continue.
Speaker 3: So you need to stop being a baby
and stop watching your door and come out and
face the American citizens that you serve.
If you want to be a big girl, you need to
get rid of your diaper and come out, be able
to talk to the American citizens.
Speaker 1: Putting aside that Marjorie Taylor
Greene is a congresswoman, this kind of behavior,
you know, take off your diaper, this kind
of behavior is humiliating and embarrassing
for any adult to be seen doing.
But it's not just a random person.
It happens to be someone who's now a member
of Congress herself, Marjorie Taylor Greene.
Now, there is another aspect to this Friday.
AOC told reporters that Greene is, quote,
deeply unwell and clearly needs help.
And her kind of fixation has lasted for several
years.
Now, this is something that remains difficult
because on the one hand, you see that video
of Marjorie Taylor Green and you see her speeches
and her behavior and the way she speaks and
looks at people, it's sort of obvious that
she's unwell.
There does seem to be a mental illness component
here.
But in addition to that, she's a radical Republican
who doesn't deserve to be in Congress because
of her beliefs.
Mental health is a major issue, which we don't
stigmatize on this program.
And Marjorie Taylor Green does seem to need
help if a doctor determines so medication
as well.
But we can't pretend this is only mental illness.
And that's why every time we bring this up
and I'm sort of glad she did, because it allows
us the opportunity to talk about it.
When we talk about, oh, this person is saying
crazy things politically.
They're mentally ill.
It's not that simple.
Marjorie Taylor Green is different than Mitt
Romney.
Mitt Romney has views that I disagree with,
but I've never seen an indication that Mitt
Romney seems to be unwell in the way that
Marjorie Tailoring is unwell.
But that doesn't excuse the disgusting political
beliefs either.
We can't pretend it's only mental illness.
It's also a radicalized, indoctrinated individual
who's harassing a member of Congress regularly
if an employee at most companies.
Did this to another employee, they would be
fired, period, that's it, and the Republican
Party is so sick, the voters that is, that
Marjorie Taylor Green is fundraising off of
these confrontations.
So absolutely off the rails and unclear if
there will be any consequences to that.
We also learned that Marjorie Taylor Green
is involved in a tax fraud.
Let's talk about
that next.